we're taking a look at the Oklahoma at
Oklahoma City to see how national issues
are playing out on the local level in
our continuing series American Voices
Republican Mick Cornett is the
longest-serving big-city mayor in the
country during his four terms in office
Oklahoma City has created 100,000 new
jobs and 94 hundred new businesses it's
also invested nearly two billion dollars
in schools and infrastructure well they
help improve public health Mayor Cornett
put his city on a diet his weight-loss
program helps citizens lose a collective
1 million pounds between 2007 and 2012
Mara Cornett is now running for governor
of Oklahoma good morning team as
Jumeirah morning Gail you're getting all
the residents in shape but you said
though that it started with you well
yeah we had been placed on a list of the
most obese cities in the country and
then I got on the scales and lo and
behold realized I was part of the
problems you didn't know you were obese
did you not have a mirror you know you
gave two or three pounds you know I
really do understand that because
sometimes you don't see yourself and you
have to have a picture to put it all in
perspective so when you saw your own
numbers you said oh my gosh I'm part of
the problem I've got to lose some weight
and I see you're wearing a Fitbit I mean
is that how you did it and is that an
inspiration for well I do 10,000 steps a
day it's just a little bit more of
accountability but really when I'm at
Oklahoma City almost everybody comes up
to me in a restaurant to see what I'm
eating but to see if it's on my life
they have a lot of accountability
partners did people say though mr. mayor
get out of my life why are you bugging
me about how happy I am I think people
were just glad someone stood up and
talked about health you know it's it's a
little bit invasive and so I think the
kind of the unannounced strategy of our
obesity problem was just to ignore it
and hope it would go away and I kind of
forced a conversation about it I said I
don't know what how we're gonna fix this
but we got to talk about it you said the
city was so good for cars I mean you
really changed the whole look of the
city talk about what you did we had
built the city where automobile traffic
flowed freely and still does we have
relatively no traffic congestion but
there was a toll on our bodies that that
that infrastructure designed around cars
was was paying it was hard to cross the
streets there weren't sidewalks in very
many places we didn't have enough
jogging and biking trails and so we've
now implemented changes
the built environment to create a
healthier city yeah some cities just
don't have walkways right but to walk to
a grocery store children can't walk to
school in a lot of places they don't
have the infrastructure there but we're
trying to fix that well speaking of
infrastructure your focus not only on
the infrastructure in your city and in
your state but in the nation as a whole
and you've talked to the president about
this what what did you say to him well I
talked to him about ways that local
governments can partner with the federal
government and that's what the
president's looking for he doesn't want
the federal government to be the sole
provider of infrastructure projects
anymore and so he's looking for local
governments to come up with cities and
counties and States and maybe even
Indian tribes to kind of combine
resources and look how we can invest in
some higher levels of technology as it
applies to infrastructure when I talk to
mayor's though the thing they need is
the money where's the money gonna come
well we've been creative and how we we
fund projects but we started something
about 25 years ago called Maps
metropolitan area projects but a penny
on the dollar sales tax for a certain
number of years and through time we've
developed some confidence we've done
what we said we're going to do and it's
allowed us to build a lot of
infrastructure projects debt-free and on
time so so if this doesn't need a
federal response in terms of federal
money has a lot of Mayors are saying
we're squeezing every penny we can get
they're even worried about driverless
cars because there won't be parking fees
they can grab so so a federal money is
not the cure-all here for in front of
our projects required federal funding
sometimes we would get a few additional
dollars thrown in because they like to
pile on we're where local governments
are investing but we were clear to
always do it with local money and meet
the voters expectation you learn
something new every day and this happens
to be something I've learned 12% of
Oklahoma City's residents are
foreign-born what are your thoughts on
the president's views on immigration and
daca in particular well immigration is a
federal issue and the federal government
certainly has to secure the border when
the federal government fails to secure
the border
it falls on local law enforcement all
across the country and we are spending a
lot of dollars as mayors in cities all
around the country trying to deal with
the influx of illegal immigration so
what's a real problem
it's a mayor you can't put off problems
when you look in Washington you got an
advice form we know they got to get
things done I mean it's all politics all
the time
people are tired of it you know that
they want they want to vote they want an
issue and present it and addressed and
then move on to the next issue they want
governing people are tired of all
politics all day long yeah go ahead no
politics then in Oklahoma City less we
have less politics no but I'm fascinated
by you mr. mayor because you went from
TV anchor to mr. mayor and now you're
running for governor so when you were
anchoring the news all that time how
long were you a news anchor nearly 20
years nearly 20 years were you thinking
politics is what I really want to do I
think everyone in the press gallery is
always thinks I could do better than
that I just decided to spined out if I
could so now that John is here you're
gonna be running for governor right
that's correct
all right well Mayor Cornett thank you
so much for having you look great by the
grass how much weight I lost about 40
pounds
all right good the rest of the city
Oklahoma City staying slim